Lara Croft's latest adventure isn't just
for Xbox owners anymore rise of the Tomb
Raider hits PC on january 28 developer
Crystal Dynamics teamed up with Nexus
software for the PC version of the game
which can run in beautiful 4k if your
computer is up to snuff the full list of
minimum specs is shown here Co studio
head Ron Rosenberg stated PC players are
a passionate devoted audience and we
know they'll embrace the version created
for their systems rise of the Tomb
Raider will be available both physically
and digitally you can download the game
from steam the Windows Store or Square
Enix's store for 60 bucks or grab the
digital deluxe edition for 90 and get
yourself a season pass to you can also
grab the collector's edition from Square
Enix's online store that version
includes the digital game season pass a
12-inch statue of Lara replicas of her
journal and jade necklace and a steel
case it'll set you back 150 dollars
gamespot named Rises the tomb raider one
of the best games of 2015 and now you
have more ways to play it playstation 4
owners will have to wait till the
holiday season for their copy of the
game but you'll hear more about that
version when we do until then keep
writing those tombs